in the recent state of play presentation
for The Last of Us - there's a bit where
Ellie sneaks up on a woman playing a
PlayStation Vita interrogator at
knifepoint and then stabs her in the
neck when she tries to retaliate Ellie
says something like that was dumb under
her breath while she wipes the blood of
his switchblade the first time I saw
that scene drew my own play through the
game I winced and I winced again when I
saw it in the state of play not just
because I was bummed about the loss of a
fellow PS Vita appreciate her and not
just because the violence was so
shocking and ruthless I mean I'm playing
Mortal Kombat 11 - so a third stab is
kind of something I could handle it's
the way the kill was choreographed in
frames to be so cold and understated
that made it feel almost nauseating the
close-up the gurgles the way the camera
lingers after the stab really made me
squirm in my seat and I thought they're
really gonna devote this much gory
detail the death of his super minor
character and a big part of why it felt
so uncomfortable was because it was an
ice-cold move from Ellie a character who
I first knew and still kind of see in my
mind as a young relatively innocent
teenager but at this point in the last
of his part - she's obviously not the
same person she's seen a lot of [ __ ] and
I mean a lot of [ __ ] I've also seen a
lot of [ __ ] including the lengthy
gameplay portion of the Last of Us part
two that immediately precedes what was
shown in the set of play it's about two
hours in length and even just from this
small portion of the full game it's
easier to see that despite half a
million the last of his part - isn't its
level structures when you compare it to
the original it's going a few extra
steps to make its grisly wealth as
believable and confronting as possible
I'm about to describe most of the
chapter to you here but don't worry
there won't be any story spoilers all
the b-roll you'll see here is probably
stuff you've seen already so it won't
match up perfectly to what I saw
personally anyway this particular
chapter of the game starts off with
Ellie setting out on our own with the
goal to traverse the overgrown Seattle
streets in order to reach a hospital
these kinds of in-between travelling
sections will be familiar if you've
played the first loss of us they're
mostly linear sections of exploration
with minimal enemy encounters where you
can focus on searching the environment
scavenging for useful materials and
learning more about those who came
before you
in the last first part to this chapter
shows off an area that's got a lot more
to it than first appears you can spend
quite a bit of time exploring a number
of optional spaces if you've got a keen
eye these places often blend right in to
the rest of the city but are filled with
supplies
environmental puzzles and I mean
counters and side stories it might be
something as simple as searching the
employees only area in a convenience
store for crafting materials or
something a little more dangerous like a
ritzy diner filled with a bunch of
infected but also probably a bunch of
extra supplies I mean this is a place
you can certainly skip altogether if
you're not up for it
the solution here might involve steps
such as finding away outside the
building by breaking glass windows which
by the way is one of the most satisfying
actions to perform in this game and then
finding some rope and creating your own
way to swing into the room by our
another window an even more
time-consuming side area in this chapter
and revolved multi-story residential
block with its own subplot to uncover as
you go from apartment to apartment
culminating in something pretty
surprising which is something I'm
looking forward to talking to others
about when they experience it these
slightly more involved side sections are
usually more rewarding too you might
find a safe whose code you need to work
out by looking at environmental clues
you might find a place to upgrade your
guns something that's also really high
on the list of satisfying actions in
this game you'll find trading cards to
collect a thing that might prompt Ellie
to write a personal journey entry you
can read or books that unlock a whole
new skill tree fairly and getting the
sense that all this great stuff could so
easily be missed completely once you
move on really motivated me to pay extra
attention to the world and keep poking
around every corner I always felt like I
could be overlooking something and that
makes the world seem very full now Ellie
eventually finds herself swimming in the
sewers which is gross also you can swim
in the hospice part too and the chapter
starts the heat up by serving you a
bunch of large-scale combat encounters
you arrive at an overgrown city park
area and you're introduced to one of the
game's enemy factions often referred to
as scars they're the robed figures
introduced in the game's 2017 teaser
trailer and then later seen in the e3
2018 gameplay reveal trailer the group
behave like hunters methodically
sweeping the area in pairs
preferring silent weapons like bows and
melee objects and they communicate with
each other by whistling which can be
pretty unnerving getting hit by one of
their arrows will result in Ellie
continuing to lose health until she can
find the breathing room to remove it
which means taking on scars head-on can
be a little more damage
than usual now this park era you first
encounter them in is covered in tall
grass allowing you plenty of opportunity
to move around the area unseen and
perform guerrilla strikes from behind
before quickly escaping and re-entering
stealth the following area the entirety
of which can be seen to me
III 2018 gameplay reveal trailer I
mentioned they sees you encountering a
large group of scars in a more exposed
urban setting
it's a multi-story car park in a section
of a freeway as you've probably seen in
that trailer evasion and the use of the
new ability to go prone and hide under
vehicles gives you a few more strategies
to consider it's important to note that
most of these bigger combat areas allow
you to move on without killing every
last enemy something that will be
familiar to anyone who's played
uncharted 4 but me I never really did
that I really enjoy how fluid weighty
and well animated the combat is in the
loss of his part - at the risk of
sounding like a psychopath the
presentation of every action gives an
oomph so satisfying I can't bear to
leave an enemy standing as a missed
opportunity in the same way I can't
leave a stone unturned during
exploration
I love the act of throwing a brick at an
enemy or shooting them in the leg to
stun them and then sprinting in to
finish them off with a big hit
I love the satisfaction of attracting a
patrol to a certain location and then
landing a particularly opportune Molotov
cocktail I like going toe-to-toe with a
hulking melee enemy so I can make le
perfectly dodge their every strike and
give them a death by a thousand
switchblade cuts and that all leads us
directly into the state of play gameplay
demo featuring the hospital combat area
MS PlayStation Vita and cold cold
violence after these long combat
encounters the game just about had me
convinced that in this universe le is
way more sadistic than Joel when it
comes to combat that's thanks in parts
of the technology allowing for a more
realistic depiction of bodily mutilation
of course for better or worse it's also
thanks to the fact that Ellie always has
her switchblade on her which means
stealth takedowns usually involve
multiple torso and head stabbings which
is a feeling that I am NOT a fan of
imagining and there's also something to
be said about the way that Ellie
haphazardly duct-tapes a couple of
knives - a wooden plank and then uses
that to go to town on these human beings
I mean holy crap but the ruthless nature
of combat is also amplified dramatically
by the ways in which the enemies now
react and speak to one another something
that's more prominent with the
soldier-like faction that guards the
hospital
as opposed to the previous group of
scars plenty of videogame enemies have
Banta and box of course but when an
enemy in the last of his pots who
discovers the body of someone they know
and they say something to the effect of
oh god Alex no with genuine sounding
grief and anger I can't help but feel a
little guilty and when I shoot someone
in the torso but don't quite hit the
critical mark and they're like screaming
and like gurgling on the floor I can't
help beating myself up a little bit for
giving them a slow painful death it's a
lie
now I've seen a lot of people joke about
the presence of a PlayStation Vita in
the last of this part - these people
obviously don't understand the joys of
an oled screen nice clicky buttons and
like a lot of really great Japanese
games but anyway the more important
thing to note is the game the dead woman
was very obviously playing on it the
game was hotline Miami a game that
basically requires you to pull off long
strings of gruesomely creative kills in
a bloodthirsty rampage and mostly lets
you revel in it if you've never played
it hotline miami has vivid neon colors
and a thumping electronic soundtrack
that helps build a haze in which you can
kind of forget about everything except
doing the best murders it's hard not to
wonder about this weird Easter Egg and
start to think about the parallels in
comparison to the game at hand the loss
of his parts who also requires you to
pull off long strings of gruesome
creative kills but the difference here
is that the last of us feels like it
wants you to see those actions with
perfect clarity it's presented in a way
for you to feel the pain of every cut
blow and shot you give and receive and
the result is way more intense than the
first game there's definitely an
excitement when you land a clutch shot
with your last bullet or get a good jump
on an enemy and clobber them to death
but it still doesn't let you shy away
from everything around the fringes that
come with those actions the melee combat
feels really good but it's hard not to
wince when you slam a machete into a
person's shoulder or take them down with
a knife to the side of the head the
damage modeling is satisfying but
there's always gonna be a bit of a shock
when someone's head explodes and my
rifle shot or someone's skin gets melted
by a Molotov and when the other enemy
characters call out the name of the
guard dog whose head you just exploded
in front of them it's really hard not to
feel like a bad person and whether this
approach translates well to the rest of
the game is something you'll just have
to wait until June 19 to discover I've
been in Ventura and thanks for watching
[Music]
you